c'est l'un des deux co présidents du
parti social démocrate
le spd qui vient de déclencher cette
nouvelle polémique outre-rhin
pourtant partenaires de la coalition au
pouvoir
norbert walter bau riams assure vouloir
en finir avec la présence des armes
nucléaires américaines sur le sol
allemand
je défends une position claire contre le
stationnement la mise à disposition et
bien sûr l'utilisation d'armes
nucléaires
je m'oppose à l'acquisition de chasseurs
de remplacement chargé de transporter
des bombes nucléaires
cette prise de position est également
critiqué par les conservateurs de la cdu
ou d'angela merkel si elle était
appliquée cette proposition marquerait
surtout une rupture radicale dans la
politique de sécurité allemandes qui
place le pays sous la protection du
clerc américaine
la critique émanant du spd vise
notamment le projet de renouvellement de
la flotte allemande d'avions de chasse
aux européens tornado bientôt obsolète
ces chasseurs doivent être remplacés par
45 f 18 américain destiné à poursuivre
le déploiement des armes nucléaires
américaines dans le cadre de la force de
dissuasion de l'otan en europe
actuellement les états unis
disposeraient de 150 bombes nucléaires
sur le vieux continent selon les
estimations leur présence provoque
depuis des décennies des divergences au
sein de la classe politique et de
l'opinion allemande
cette prise de position du leader du spd
n'est d'ailleurs pas anodine alors que
son parti souhaite défendre une ligne
pacifiste et anti nucléaire avec pour
objectif de convaincre une large partie
de l'électorat de gauche avant les
élections législatives prévues en
septembre 2021